if things go right we have a perfect
Camry that completely blows everything
out of the water
Sam's dream can't so we are knee-deep in
video shoots right now and we have
another one coming up Jon Snow wick
Romanies man forecast says it should be
a sunny afternoon look at that looks
like it's beautiful it looks like we're
in the north we have a really really
small crew for this I have to figure out
a way to shoot this thankfully there's
some new gear in the studio that I'm
very excited to try out and might solve
all our problems for the last few years
we've been getting it into our heads
that there's only one camera that we
should be using on set and that's the
red why the footage looks great tons of
frame rates huge resolutions big
downside the red by itself isn't
cumbersome but the moment you have to
start combining with other gear it
becomes very cumbersome and we're doing
smooth shots we need to full dolly set
up traps and stuff like that or we need
a big powerful gimbal that can handle
the weight of a real full-size camera
the reason I was interested in bringing
this is because the kind of goes against
all of that Blackmagic pocket
4k pros of the Blackmagic it's small
it's light it's got a touchscreen it's
4k it shoots raw Nico likes to take that
footage and stretch all the colors apart
and remix it and make it look really
good and we need footage that can hold
up to that process but it's got some
downsides
battery life it's really inconsistent so
far hopefully we bring enough batteries
to last us the day because if we don't
then we're screwed
secondly it's small enough to put on a
tiny gimbal that's made for small
cameras it's the crane 3 lab I'm a huge
fan of design gimbals obviously the pros
are we get smooth footage all gimbals
react a little differently to camera
raids I don't fingers crossed on this
one have a lot of confidence that it's
gonna turn out well if things go right
we have a perfect camera rig that
completely blows everything out of the
water before
there weren't many other options this
size that could give us the footage that
we needed right now it's got a really
really high probability of dethroning
what I would have considered the perfect
camera to be like a week or two ago I
want to find the perfect camera
regardless whether or not I've already
found it or if you're about to discover
a new perfect camera the red is gonna
handle more challenging lighting
situations buyers in this camera well
well let red just has a better sensor
it's apparently fine this camera is on
par with the Scarlett
which we got back movie first got her
first read remember tether we shot
tether on the Scarlet bow your life is a
little short but you can turn it on in
three seconds so this is kind of like
honestly this is kind of like the camera
I was dreaming about a decade ago and
the red was kind of the stopgap say hey
mean can two one action can we do one
last one yeah I know where I'm kind of
getting all the kinks worked out right
now this practice helps a lot
action ghost ghost where are you this is
our Genki log dog oh you're acting keep
it as low as possible when you come up
to here yeah great your acting is like
moderate above-average this is a great
cinematic tool tool it's a video with a
lot of action in it if things go right
we have an actual perfect camera setup
here that's how I technically reload the
batteries they just drop them great
awesome reset back up guys
Niko has to flip up that bow into his
hands knock an arrow and fire it without
any editing or VFX Niko this is just a
shot of you doing a trick alright
there's no getting around it
alright you ready for victory yep to go
people are gonna go oh he didn't do it
for real what would you do
[Music]
action I know you could do that I never
doubted them digging this crane 3 and
Blackmagic pocket combination 2 seconds
you take my jacket off so I can put 100%
energy into this 3 2 1 action today I
use the camera that I've never shot with
before and I use the gimbal I've never
used before
it actually went really really well the
only gripe I have with it is that when
you're shooting handheld like this even
for actually still get like the handheld
DSLR jitters the batteries kinda went
through about 6 or 7 that said I've
saved more time today than almost
anything else here's the crazy part
this ain't a sponsored video this ain't
sponsored by black magic yet please
yo welcome to you what we thought was
gonna be day to another production went
the official route got their permits got
their permissions so they technically
have the up on us on the location they
get it for their shoot so we're trying
to figure out if there's a solution
let's move out
maybe we could fight them maybe a more
peaceful option is the way to go here so
we're gonna go try to find a new spot if
we don't find the spot then we're kind
of screwed on the day we'll see how it
goes
hopefully as pine trees kind of look the
same it's like a half-hour towards that
other bridge wow this is apocalyptic
this is just straight-up apocalyptic
right now those are some good speed
bumps it looks like a lawn a brown lawn
I don't see if we did like an apocalypse
short-film
down here you just bring some gas masks
and film become the wastelands
Graceland's it's a pill beam an equal
sign monster question mark
the tagline for the movie is what really
lies beneath question mark thanks
backing it up but we're just gonna pack
it up call it a day and come back and
get this thing done
so unfortunately we got kicked out of
our location for day two stresses a
little high so we're gonna take a moment
have a quick jam session and say thank
you to our loyal patrons
[Music]
not Canadian spy will Robertson Eddie's
ain't no Iranian Guerrero jr. bleh flash
Hendrix Sean Patrick William Perry
[Music]
Taylor Dunbar asteroid Gigi unwise
aboubakar Palin Almanza the lion's head
in YouTube channel Philip Oxford master
one ace one Gary Dahms
[ __ ] Wednesdays Brian and Kotick butch
cube James Bailey didn't forget about
you buddy Raymond nabob and Caleb
gallant Thank You patrons hey what's up
so I'm editing the footage now that we
shot on first day this is our first time
using the Blackmagic Cinema Camera
pocket Cinema Camera 4k bmpcc 4k I mean
the Sampson raving about it now that I
see the footage it's such a breath of
fresh air so we were shooting in
something called black magic raw or just
be raw or raw some broth a raw codec but
it's a compressed rock codec you know
you're rockin trolls now I have patrols
over the shots so here's me running
right right this shots really bright now
I can fix most of that with the rock
controls I have my rock controls for my
Blackmagic raw file and I can drop my
ISO a little bit get that panned Allen
where I want it and let's say my white
balance is off I could just change the
white balance after effect now the
Blackmagic camera doesn't have as much
dynamic range as the red I have a little
fix for that things tend to become d
saturated as they get brighter
I simply pulled the highlights all the
way down I can really saturate them I
can even go further here but that
obviously looks bad
I'm taking that bright sunlight I'm not
making it quite so extreme and there we
go that's not too bad I love being able
to change my ISO after the fact I love
being able to change my white balance
after the fact the fact that black magic
has added that to the black magic such
an essential thing I'm so glad they've
done it in scarlet was like $20,000 this
is $1,000 getting over a little bit of a
road bump your back looks like we got it
all to ourselves
[Music]
you may have caught up with me last time
when I was working my Russian lens set
went to Crete probably what I would call
like one of the coolest vintage
anamorphic looks you can get on a budget
today the finally complete let me give
you a tour I'm a huge fan of anamorphic
lenses I didn't want to drop $20,000 so
the next closest thing were these
Russian lenses because they're sharp
they're a little rough around the edges
to give you that vintage aesthetic
you'll see it in this video a lot
they're all Prime's they're not as crisp
and sharp but it works for pieces like
this because it's medieval and you know
so that vintage s that it works just
makes it so actually why everything
looks like a little weird and distorted
on the background but does matter cause
it's still crisp in the foreground you
know huh this is so nice lens or is it
the bad lens Tony's gonna do a fall
without a pad on the ground tend to call
these a bump it's a point of pride among
stuntmen that comes time to take the
fall they do it for real I'm gonna I'm
gonna hit him in the ankles gonna flip
all the way over and land on his back so
now it's on us like nail it
within the first maybe the second time a
foot man it's gonna be it's gonna be
cool you want to rehearse it first on
the pad so that way make sure you can do
the fall real Sun I have to do a crazy
ass fight today and then go and wreck
somewhere else for somebody else
tomorrow you have to be in good shape
the whole time that's very true that's
why you got to always head up this is
about my older stank I told me yeah even
if you're doing like a little side fall
where your elbow can't touches the
ground just cut up is like we do it ten
thousand times over like 20 years that
adds up and he's like this always be
safe
that's the job of a stunt mask carrying
pads I think it 1% and I'm not gonna do
this with that 1% battery and I don't
want to do a stunt where someone's
hitting the ground risk the cameras
shutting off this is how I reload in
real life see we have philosophy that if
some man hurts himself in the shot
that's the shot you have to use
flap flap fine language yeah yeah so all
the stun guys have done their fall
without pads so I must do at least one
it's not much of a 3q1
action yeah I'm not a [ __ ] I can roll
with the homies all done Johnson Oh has
a Bane lead 90% of it last one last one
if you can if you can spare me one more
pint of acting one action
[Music]
we've been recording all day
Sam has 50 seconds left on his card we
have one shot to get which is the ending
of the video although it's beautiful
valley 50 seconds the first take needs
to be a perfect take
[Music]
how may we can finish this tighten tuck
need someone huh that's website that's
whatever us in the candidates
something happened I think I made it to
nothing I mean I suddenly get rolling
wasted at all Oh story see yeah we need
we need memory now it's an emergency SD
card here for situations just like this
much memory is on this card 8 gigabytes
that's enough
Alec series probably shittiest cheapest
car brain is this
[Music]
the magic staff it really is a magic
staff I feel like it's like a scepter
just like my big Ruby with like magic
powers up in this you did it it worked
it worked against all odds it worked far
better than any of any right to work
there's one shot here now it starts off
as a dolly in and becomes an orbiting
shot right here dolly in then boom
breaks out that becomes an orbiting shot
if you wanted to get that shot with a
heavier camera traditionally it laid on
dolly track and eat your dolly shot and
you're orbiting shot would be like a
Steadicam shot you really wouldn't be
able get both you're getting a dolly was
getting a crane move you're getting a
Steadicam move you're getting a tripod
move the tripod move less crew lighter
ray I mean I would totally shoot a
full-on movie like this you get the
flexibility you need super creative
you basically have all the language of
cinema at your fingertips you can commit
to going into any type of shot you
imagine instantly this sounds like 80%
of the way there even though this
Blackmagic urge was great I'm not gonna
make my perfect camera yet we'll have to
see which one is the true perfect camera
subscribe to find out if it is and
please follow us on Instagram that
corridor digital double tap into hit
that like button so often your fingers
are good sword I broke my screen because
I double tapped to fast camera rigs are
cool and all but you know it's also
pretty cool the fact that we have
restock the corridors store at corridor
digital dot store link in the
description but check out this hoodie
it's nice and comfy and even zips up and
down it's got a nice little hood but not
just that we also have this t-shirt this
mystic tee has the same design as what
you'll find on the hoodie but this has
got the sweetheart pattern that I like a
lot okay now we do have a limited number
of these items so if you don't act now
you might run out don't throw away this
opportunity and link is in the
description for more of these t-shirts
and hoodies that you could find at the
corridor digital fast store do not throw
away this opportunity this opportunity
because
this opportunity fraternity remember oh
yeah this opportunity don't throw away
this opera way this opportunity to guess
the sweet merchandise this opportunity
to miss out on our crown jewel of our
software dangit software